So, let's say that we had these five instructions, and for now, all that matters
for write of the write dependencies is, which registers are we writing to.
So let's say that the first instruction is writing to R1,
it's computing some result, it doesn't really matter what it is.
And then the second one is writing to R4. Then we have R7 and R8 being written.
And then the fifth instruction is also supposed to write to R4, so
we will see that the problem will be with the second and the fifth instruction
writing to R4. So what can happen is, let's say that there is a,
read after write dependence between the first and the second instruction. So,
what's now going to happen is, there will be some cycle, let's call it cycle 5,
in which R1 is going to execute. R4 cannot execute.
It has to wait. And it will execute here in cycle 6.
Meanwhile these instructions will execute, because they don't have any
dependencies. Now in our five stage pipeline what's going to happen is basically
this instruction is going to move to the mem stage where it doesn't do anything
because none of them are really memory instructions. And then so will these. And
then what's going to happen is in the next cycle this instruction will write
this results. So now, R1 gets written. This instruction is also going to write
this results, so R7 is going to be written. This one writes R8, and
this one writes R4. However the second instruction has executed here so
it is going to go to the MEM stage here and write the result here and
it is going to be R4. So if you look at what is the final result in R4.
The final result in R4 is whatever was the last thing written to it,
which is going to be this value. But it should have been this value.
Because when the program that wrote this they wrote it this way so that they
could expect that our R4 would retain the value from this fifth instruction and
not from the instruction. So basically the programmer wanted this to become
temporarily this. But then take a new value here and
that's kind of the last value after these five instructions.
But that didn't happen. So that is a problem. Why is it a problem,
I mean why did it occur? Well because this instruction got delayed, so
we have executed these two instructions out of order.
This is the second instruction and it writes in the eight cycle.
This is the fifth instruction, but it writes in the seventh cycle. So
basically we have basically written the result in the wrong order. Our I mean,
it's, it's an order different from the order in which they were supposed to
execute in the program. So in order to fix this, one solution will be. So
to fix this, one solution would be to not have this instruction write the result
here. Instead it would have to be stalled here and here. And finally, write
this result here. So a real processor might, see in some way, needs to figure
out how to do this. Because these rights need to happen in the correct order.